coming to you from the historic Largo
Theatre in Hollywood it's common
I'm Andy Richter tonight
Will Ferrell now here he is :
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Conan O'Brien here let me briefly
explain where I am right now I'm sitting
in the iconic Largo theater why am I
here well a lot of theaters across the
country are struggling right now and we
really wanted to help one of the local
empty theaters here in Los Angeles so we
chose Largo Largo is a very special
place to everyone in the Los Angeles
comedy community just about everybody's
performed here and here's a fun fact I
started here doing improv that's right I
got my first laughs here in 1985 and got
my last laughs here in 1991 no laughs
since a bit of a drought no me laughing
it myself doesn't count anyway let me
assure you we are following all of the
health protocols while we're here at the
Largo I'm here with a bare-bones crew
everyone's wearing a mask
everyone's socially distance and the
theater itself is completely empty in
fact the only person sitting here
tonight is my assistant Sona
hey Sona hey how's it going see I'm
gonna feed off sona's energy I'm gonna
take that energy and ride it like a wave
and it's gonna give me the energy I need
to entertain you and you know there's
another reason actually that we moved
locations like a lot of people across
the country probably like you I've been
inside my home with my family for months
now and I thought it would be nice to
kind of switch it up so this is actually
my first time away from my wife since
the quarantine started so I just want to
briefly check in see how she's doing
without me
he's gone he's gone oh well she'll cheer
up eventually anyway given everything
that's happening right now on our planet
just we're given with a lot let's face
it sometimes you just need to escape
well luckily our newest sponsor has you
covered
take a look heartbreaking milestone
nearly 100,000 lives lost to the corona
virus pandemic killer Hornets invading
the US and Canada
[Music]
want to get away now you can SpaceX will
see the offering trips to outer space
SpaceX you are now free to leave this
hellhole thank you good people at SpaceX
anyway we got a great show tonight Will
Farrell is gonna be joining us you
excited about that Sona Will Ferrell